of all the hundreds of colorful
supporting characters on The Simpsons
there's no one quite as memorable or
bizarre as Krusty the Klown he's a
complicated man with an elaborate story
so here it is boys and girls the
backstory of Krusty the Klown the 1991
Simpsons episode like father like clown
provides a lot of information about
Krusty's early years and explains why he
acts the way he does in short he has
some major daddy issues after Bart
Krusty's biggest fan helps clear him
from a robbery charge he comes to the
Simpsons house for dinner when he
delivers the blessing in Hebrew some of
the family seems confused
well at least Homer does funny Doug Lisa
ever observant understands that Krusty
is Jewish and when she asks him
questions about it he breaks down in a
fit of crying the rest of the episode is
a riff on the jazz singer both the 1927
and 1980 films which tells the story of
a man who wants to be an entertainer and
not a cantor in his synagogue but in the
Simpsons version Krusty has a falling
out with his father because he rejects
his desire for him to study the Torah at
yeshiva in favor of being a clown we
also learned that Krusty is just a stage
name for the man born Herschel
krustofski in Springfield's Lower East
Side Rusty's father was rabbi hyman
krustofski who felt that his son should
live a serious life and that clowns were
not respected members of society before
giving up on a quiet life as a Jewish
scholar Krusty attended yeshiva as a
child while he tried to make his father
happy he couldn't suppress his natural
urges to clown around what are you doing
in that bathroom away from the door this
instant
one night while Krusty performed at a
convention of Rabbis everything came
crashing down
young Hershel with his identity
concealed by makeup did his act to the
delight of the crowd which included his
father everything was fine until another
rabbi took Krusty's Seltzer bottle and
sprayed the young performer instantly
revealing his true identity to rabbi
krustofski embarrassed and angry that
Krusty was clowning against his wishes
he disowned his son right then and there
forced to leave home Krusty began his
career as a street mime in Tupelo
Mississippi eventually he got his own
show and built a personal empire however
he always missed his dad after not
speaking for 25 long years Krusty and
his estranged father finally put aside
their differences and reunited for good
over the course of his career Krusty the
Klown has made a lot of money and he
also seems to make a lot of bad
decisions
regrettably for crusty the combination
of those two things has resulted in some
serious vices which have taken a toll on
his finances and his health Krusty
possesses an almost pathological need to
accrue and waste money he lights
cigarettes with hundred dollar bills and
extremely valuable comic books he
continually blows cash on bad
investments and he's a fan of expensive
omelettes made with endangered Condor
eggs on top of all that crusty is
clearly a gambling addict who bets
unwisely on events with virtually
assured outcomes such as Harlem
Globetrotters games or operas at one
point Krusty has to open a clown college
to pay off his gambling debts to the mob
it seemed like a great solution at the
time but it came with some unexpected
downsides burn that seat
then there's the topic of Krusty's many
addiction issues to deal with the stress
of his high profile career he turned
into a chain-smoking alcoholic who was
hooked on the painkiller Percodan he
also once confessed to Bart that
freebasing moon rocks was the only thing
left that still gave him a kick
basically if there's an illicit
substance around Krusty will find a way
to sniff it out perhaps as a function of
his self-destructive habits his age or
some combination of the two
Krusty the Klown suffers from a host of
medical problems he's mentioned that he
has diabetes and is concerned about
experiencing massive organ failure plus
in a flashback to an old clip from
Krusty show he has a heart attack on
stage while his young fans cheer with
delight even after being outfitted with
a pacemaker Krusty still experienced a
few more cardiac events through the
years when Homer is preparing for his
own heart procedure Krusty visits and
shows off his surgical scar he also lets
Homer know about an unexpected side
effect of his condition well I got news
for ya there's a makeup in the world of
The Simpsons Krusty might not be as
popular as he once was but his brand is
still viable enough that he can license
his name and image to appear on
countless pieces of merchandise and the
centerpiece of Krusty's licensing Empire
is Krusty Burger it's a house of horrors
unto itself selling health endangering
treats like the watch a macaques
sandwich gravy scrapings and bacon balls
I use non-disease mate from diseased
animals everyone does it
in 1984 Krusty Burger was selected to
offer the official meat flavored
sandwich of the summer olympics in a
related promotion Krusty authorized a
contest in which customers scored free
food whenever America won an event but
it was rigged to feature games dominated
by the Soviet Union after the USSR
boycotted the games the Americans
dominated leading Krusty personally to
suffer major financial losses to the
tune of 44 million dollars in the
Simpsons episode insane clown papi
Krusty signs copies of his book at a
fair and is approached by a young girl
named Sophie she closely resembles a
certain clown and well you can probably
guess what happens next
flashbacks explain how Krusty ended up
as a father and the reasons why Sophie's
mother Aaron kept him out of their
daughter's life during the early 90s
Gulf War Krusty was performing on a USO
tour and met Aaron who was an American
soldier the morning after their brief
encounter she left in a hurry to fulfill
her military orders assassinate Saddam
Hussein since Krusty's USO material
consisted mainly of jokes about the
Iraqi leader he tackled her as she fired
her rocket launcher so he could save his
act Aaron immediately strangled Krusty
to the point of unconsciousness and
never told him that he had a child when
confronted with the truth Krusty tries
to talk his
way out of the situation and admits to
Sophie that he's not exactly father
material I curse I gamble I pick fights
with homeless people like what's wrong
with your eyes
you need a claritin or something
fortunately after spending some quality
time with Sophie Krusty takes
responsibility and forges a loving
relationship with his newfound daughter
it just goes to show that after a
lifetime of endless entertaining hard
living and major regrets Krusty still
has a few surprises up his sleeve and we
can't wait to see what he does next
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Simpsons are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]